we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David p.
Um, we are getting more and more people who
are contacting me saying, David, I know I
was a youtube subscriber and Youtube has unsubscribed
me.
There is some poor connection that takes place
during this voicemail, but that's the point
that this caller is trying to make.
Take a listen.
[inaudible]
Hey David.
Um, my name is Jerry.
A long time listener, uh, and long time subscriber.
Um, uh, I just wanted to let you know that,
um, I was watching your show last night.
Everything was going fine on my end this morning.
Apparently I have been unsubscribed from.
Hmm.
Oh yeah.
It's not all in our collective heads.
It is actually happening.
I do not know and I will not, um, point fingers
at if it is malicious or just a bug.
Um, but it just happened to me, so thank you.
Keep up the good work.
Um, and have a great day.
Yeah.
So listen, here's the update.
I've communicated that this is going on to
youtube probably 20 or 25 times at this point.
They finally acknowledged that this is something
that they've been hearing, but they are claiming
number one, that it is a glitch.
But here's the really interesting thing and
this part doesn't make sense to me.
Youtube has said when a glitch shows the button
as enabled, again, that lets you subscribe.
When you're subscribed, you can't subscribe
again, the button is different when you see
the button that says subscribe.
Most people would assume, I'm not actually
subscribed.
Youtube is claiming that the glitch shows
the button as allowing them to subscribe again.
But that in reality youtube still considers
those users subscribed.
They should still see our videos in their
home feed.
That's the problem that I'm having because
the viewers that are contacting me saying
I was unsubscribed are even noticing that
because they stopped seeing our videos in
our, in their feed, they stop getting the
email notifications for our videos.
So I don't know what the truth is.
I don't think it's malicious.
I think that it is clearly something that's
going on in the youtube system that they've
been either unable or unwilling to really
drill down and figure out what's going on
and the explanation that it is only a glitch
in the button does not strike me as the right
explanation because too many people are saying,
the reason I looked into whether I was subscribed
or unsubscribed from your channel is that
I was no longer getting your videos in my,
uh, home home feed at all.
Uh, I dunno, keep telling me, uh, what your
experience has been as if this has happened
to you.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
The Trump administration is considering, uh,
unveiling a new healthcare plan in September.
Uh, the timing of that is relevant.
The contents of the plan will of course be
very, very relevant.
We will discuss that trust in scientists is
rising according to a new poll.
I believe that this is a good thing.
There are people who don't.
We are going to talk about that on today's
bonus show and we will also talk about Neil
degrasse Tyson being slammed for an insensitive
and Asinine tweet following some of the events
of this weekend.
I won't say what events, just to maybe try
to get this video, not to BD monetized on
Youtube, but some of the events of this weekend
because Neil degrasse Tyson to tweet and he
has been criticized for those tweets as they,
they being insensitive and Asinine.
Two ways to get access to this great bonus
show that I'm describing.
Become a member at www.joinpacman.comorbecomeapatronatpatrion.com/david
Pakman show.
I look forward to speaking to you on the bonus
show or otherwise on tomorrow, the David Pakman
show@davidpacman.com [inaudible].